today we're going to examine the future
of miryo after he intentionally took a
quark destroying bullet to protect arey
what a gentleman the English voice actor
for million should be hopping on my
channel in the new year for a Q&A
session so if you have any questions for
him at all make sure you're subscribed
and then leave your question in the
comment section below but without
further ado let's get into what the
future holds for this particular
character specifically I'm gonna lay out
the five most likely scenarios in no
particular order okay so we saw earlier
this season that Tamaki was hit with a
prototype version of this quote
destroying bullet which destroyed his
quote for about 12 hours or so after
this the she is like I seemingly created
the ultimate version of this bullet that
could destroy quarks permanently but
hear me out here what if in the same way
that Tamaki's body was able to recover
his quark back you know after a good
night's sleep what if the bullet that
hit me Ryo isn't actually permanent but
rather it just takes a super long time
for the power to return I mean the she
is like I aren't exactly the world's
greatest scientists they're an
organization consisting of drunks street
fighters and talking plush toys what if
the drug that they believed would
destroy quarks permanently only actually
destroyed them for a long period of time
there say about five years now
story-wise this is probably the lamest
possible way that myrio could get his
quark back but for me it's entirely
possible so in short if the she is like
I are wrong and the bullet is not
permanently destroying quirks then I
guess Mario's gonna wake up in like five
years and just fall straight through the
ground so basically like this pic but a
more updated version overall I'm gonna
rate the possibility of this happening
as a six out of ten now moving on to a
more likely cause of action and number
two on this list we have the idea that
Mario does actually remain Quercus for
the rest of his life and as a big Maria
fan I gotta say I would hate to see this
happen
but if Mario does remain Qualis then all
hope is not lost my friends during his
fight with overhaul the big man himself
said that there's more to this character
than just his quirk Murillo has the
heart of a hero and he wants to save a
million people as a quark this guy you
might not save that many but if he
became like a police officer for example
in much the same way that all my best
friend is a police officer then he can
still have a real
impact on people's lives and by
remaining quickness it would give
greater meaning to his sacrifice like he
truly did give up his dream to save this
one girl something that only a true hero
could do I reckon this is a possible
path for Miriah to follow as he could
still be useful in safe people either
that or he gets a normal job which in a
world full of superpowers would be
pretty sucky overall I'd rate the
possibility of this a seven out of ten
it would definitely have the biggest
emotional impact if he was to remain
Qualis now in third place on this list
we have the possibility that Airy world
rewind myrio back into a state where his
body still has his quirk if you don't
want to know any spoilers whatsoever
then pause this video and skip to the
next item on this list the time stamp
that you should skip to is on the screen
but for those of you that don't really
care or already know Knight I foresaw
that Miriah would become a great hero
one day and taking him at his word the
natural assumption to become a great
hero is that you must have a quirk right
and to me the most logical way of this
happening is by every doing it this is
because it would complete the circle of
events miryo sacrificed his quirk to
save Arry and now Arry having been saved
and being able to master her quirk is
able to return the favor by giving him
back what he lost
to save her we've seen in the manga that
there's still not a lot known about
every squirt so yes she does need time
to Train it properly before she can do
something like this so if it was to
happen I reckon it won't happen for
about maybe let's say two years and that
would possibly mean that when Muriel
gets his quirk back he can finish his
studies alongside the current class 1-a
who would be final years at that time
imagine that me Rio studying alongside
cost when a currently that would be
content I would pay to see but anyway
overall I rate the possibility of Airi
returning Mario's quirk as a 9 out of 10
I do believe that this is the most
likely cause of action especially in the
manga when you see the relationship
between me Rio and airy and obviously
given everything that's happened every
feels a massive debt to him so yeah this
is likely gonna happen but when it will
happen who knows at 4th place we have
the idea that mario does become a great
hero but with one little stipulation he
doesn't get his quirk back in the MCU we
have superheroes like Iron Man and
Hawkeye
who have no supernatural powers beyond
their normal human bodies but we've also
seen characters like spider-man who
although they already have powers they
also have a lot of power that's given to
them from the suit that they're wearing
so what if myrio as a Quercus person
like Iron Man or Hawkeye was able to get
an awesome costume that would enable him
to operate as a superhero in a world
where he'd be one of the few co-workers
people and I reckon I know someone who
design it for him too
a suit like that would definitely
supplement the downsides of not having a
quirk for me personally miryo is my
favorite character in my hero academia
and he has been for a while now and in
the manga I feel like we haven't seen
him for a long time so hopefully in the
future he does become a hero one way or
another but for now I'm reading the
likelihood of him becoming a super suit
type hero a 5 out of 10 logically
speaking heroes normally do have to have
a quirk and I've never heard of a single
hero who operates without one but just
because there's no precedent for it
doesn't mean it can't end up happening
so that's why I give it a 50-50 chance
and finally I saved the most bonkers
theory for last what if in the future
myrio doesn't get his quirk back but
acquires someone else's quirk if you see
my video explaining all meit's backstory
you'll know that his name contains the
kanji for 8 foreshadowing the fact that
he would become the 8th user by a
similar token his predecessor had the
Japanese word for 7 referencing her
being the seventh user and dec whose
name contains the kanji for a long time
ago that makes the same sound as the
kanji for 9 referencing that he is the
ninth holder horikoshi is clearly using
a scheme when naming the different uses
of one for all at least the three that
we know of and that's my really
long-winded way of saying that the toe
part of myriad Agharta can be read as 10
which possibly refers to the fact that
he would succeed Deku and become the
tenth user of one for all that's of
course what sir Knight I wanted all
along but how likely is it happen well
we know that Deku will be the number one
hero one day but we have no context
surrounding that statement
maybe Dec whose original quirk manifests
and he passes one floor to me REO or
something crazy like that I don't know
exactly but all I can tell you is that
let's say me Rio was the tenth permanent
Hall
he could become a great hero like night
I foresaw and it would tie into the
meaning behind his name though in all
likelihood this crackpot theory will
never pan out unless now probably not
overall I'd give the likelihood of me
Ryo getting one for all a three out of
ten and that's gonna do it for me today
guys those were the five most likely
things to happen to me Rio going forward
with the number one most likely thing
being that airy gives him his quote back
in the future and the next most likely
thing being that he remains Quercus for
the rest of his life so pretty
contrasting there I guess I guess we'll
have to see how it pans out and like I
said I'll be doing a Q&A with Rico
Fajardo aka the voice actor for the
million in early January hopefully early
January but you know he's a busy guy so
it might get rearranged but January is
the provisional date so for when that
happens make sure you get your questions
in but you have to be subscribed and be
sure to check out my theory discussing
why baku go was the second user of one
for all it absolutely blew up so I'd
love for you to check it out if you
haven't already peace out